UN experts reportedly say North Korea
has been sending supplies to Syria that
could help make chemical weapons this
suggests pyongyang has shipped banned
weapons to the Syrian government despite
UN sanctions the u.s. accuses Syria of
using chemical weapons against
rebel-held areas that includes the
besieged Damascus suburb of eastern
Goethe Seth Doane is the only network
correspondent in Damascus
Seth good morning good morning
airstrikes and artillery shelling
ratcheted up overnight as the government
tries to retake eastern goota a large
forty square mile area that is roughly
two times the size of Manhattan it has
densely populated areas orchards and a
web of competing militant groups that
have dug in the bombardment of eastern
Goethe continues and while militants
there may be surrounded they're partly
surrendering they regularly lobbed
mortars into areas royal to the
government just standing in these
neighborhoods you see pictures of people
who have died in the fighting people
come up with things like mortars and
shrapnel and they just brought over this
little girl and said meet her her father
was killed in the fighting signs of war
are everywhere but they're dwarfed by
the widespread destruction in eastern
buta under assault from President Bashar
al-assad's forces who hurt us aren't
civilians they are terrorist groups I'm
in candy told us do you think the
government can hurt them by sending rice
sugar or flour so far a Russian plan to
allow for a daily five-hour humanitarian
pause and hostilities has not worked
at a Damascus Hospital medical director
Nihad Asaf told us they've seen many
injuries like the ones father Cooley
sustained in the mortar attack that
killed his four-year-old son it is very
difficult to see others who suffer from
injury or anything like that one eight
agency told us this morning that these
humanitarian pauses simply won't work
because they are not long enough for aid
convoys to unload the massive amount of
supplies needed in eastern goota Gail
Seth Doane reporting from Damascus thank
you